summer is now at an end and it was a big
one for Hogwarts Legacy seems like news
is starting to slow down just a bit
giving all of us time to catch our
breath and recap all of the many
announcements that we've gotten over the
past several months but it certainly
doesn't sound like they're going to be
quiet for long Hogwarts Legacy Community
manager Chandler wood recently took to
Twitter to give a pretty big hint that
we are going to see some gameplay of
Hogwarts Legacy very soon he knows that
is something that fans have been asking
to see more of and personally I think
there are three big time questions still
remaining about Hogwarts Legacy and I
actually think an extended look at
gameplay might give us the answers to at
least two of them number one how does
time pass in Hogwarts Legacy okay I'm
kind of cheating with this one because
there are really multiple questions
rolled up into one here but I feel like
if we got an answer to how time passes
that would really give us some insight
into so much about how the rest of the
game is going to work more specifically
I'm thinking about classes here do we
have to be in class at a specific time
on a specific day or is it more of an
open-ended thing how do the day night
cycles work how does that work with the
various quests we're given along with
those classes that we just talked about
then there's the whole season system and
I know a lot of you think that Hogwarts
Legacy is going to be more than one
school year I still think it's just
going to be one single school year and
we'll get to see all four seasons in
that one school year but who knows
that's one where I would love to be
wrong on I think what's so interesting
about this one is that Avalanche really
has to make sure they strike that
balance between something that's fun to
play something that doesn't feel super
time sensitive like you're going to miss
a key deadline but then also with the
realism aspect I mean people want to
feel like they're actually taking
classes and going to school at Hogwarts
and one thing I think we have to keep in
mind here is that it's not an MMO as I
remind people time and time again it is
an action RPG so if you're looking at
realism and fun on a scale they're going
to go way more toward the fun side of
things than trying to keep things super
realistic which for some fans is
probably going to be disappointing but I
think most fans will be pretty pleased
by hearing that again that's just my
guess that we don't no we haven't seen
this yet in practice now another aspect
that is super interesting about the
classes is that they will certainly
impact the game's story in some way now
we've already even seen cutscenes for
the classes so we know we're not going
to get them every day is it every week
is it once a quarter is it just a
one-time thing you get a class are there
a couple spread out through the year can
you completely just ignore classes like
say you decide you know what I don't
really want to take potions I'm not
going to take potions a lot of people
still want to know can you skip classes
and if you do skip classes then what
happens as a result of that can you go
back and make that up or just completely
miss out on it now over the years of
video games who have tackled this
problem they've handled it in a number
of different ways on one side you have a
game like Animal Crossing which actually
uses a real world clock so if it's 8 am
in the real world it is 8 am in your
Animal Crossing or at least if it's 8 am
on your Nintendo switch so anything that
you have to do at night in Animal
Crossing you have to do at night in the
real world again unless you kind of
Tinker around with the switches settings
then you have a game like The Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild where the
weather is constantly changing the time
is constantly changing and then then
even within that you have the ability to
advance to a certain point of the day
and this system here is certainly how a
lot of games handle it however it could
be a little bit problematic for Hogwarts
Legacy because of the fact that we have
to take classes and the vast majority of
those classes take place during the
daytime hours so to summarize this one
here classes seasons and the day night
cycle they're each going to be
significant to how Hogwarts Legacy feels
to play and yet other than knowing that
all three are there and exist in the
game we actually know very little about
how these systems will work that's why
it's one of my three biggest questions
remaining moving on to number two how do
spells work in Hogwarts Legacy how many
can we have how do the finishers work
can you just Spam Avada Kedavra like
crazy now we have seen glimpses of
Hogwarts legacies HUD and plenty of the
spells in action what we haven't seen is
how we'll chain these spells together in
battle we saw from that PS5 trailer that
R2 is going to be involved somehow in
casting spells we also see the little
pop-ups in the Gameplay trailer that we
already have where R1 seems to be tied
to a pug nut know how many spells can we
have equipped at a given time and does
it all have to go on that Hut how do we
switch them in and out there's also been
quite a bit of talk among fans about the
possibility of a wheel of sorts but
we've actually seen nothing official at
all on that just yet what we do know is
that from watching the gameplay you can
chain these spells together very quickly
I mean in Rapid succession and while we
don't exactly know how many we know that
the trailers have mentioned dozens of
spells at a bare minimum and with me
being someone who is so keen on the
actual gameplay when it comes to video
games for me at least the story is
secondary I mean it's great if you have
an awesome story but we play games too
play games enjoy the actual gameplay if
I wanted to just sit and watch something
I could go watch a movie I could read a
book watch a TV show there are plenty of
other ways to get just a story but
that's what makes games so unique so
this is why to me the gameplay is so
crucial and I feel that spells and
combat how they all work together is
really going to go a long way to
determining how fun this game is to play
I have no doubt it's going to be an
absolute blast to explore I really do I
have no doubt about that whatsoever
there are going to be so many Secrets
packed in this game the adventure the
exploration is going to be top-notch
what I don't know and I just don't feel
we've seen enough yet is how the game's
gonna play and how fun it's going to be
moment to moment casting spells being in
the middle of combat upgrading all of
these things does it feel satisfying and
that is why this remains one of the
biggest questions that I still want to
know which takes us to number three who
is the Ravenclaw companion okay at first
I thought maybe I make this question is
there a rabbit claw companion but let's
be honest I mean it would be an
incredible shock if they do not include
a Ravenclaw companion I can't see them
doing that for the other three houses
but for some reason Ravenclaw is just
not included nah not happening don't see
it there is going to be a Ravenclaw
companion and this leads directly into a
follow-up question again kind of
cheating here but I gotta know why has
it been a secret for so long does this
Ravenclaw companion hold some
significance will we perhaps recognize
their last name are they from one of
those storied Wizarding World families
who we will just immediately know right
off the bat who this person is related
to I'll be honest I think it'd be
awesome I think it'd be really cool if
that were the case I think it's much
simpler than that though I think it's
more of a marketing thing I think it's
just something that Avalanche has
decided hey you know what this would be
something cool to hold and reveal later
on especially when they had to push the
game to 2023 obviously they want to have
plenty of things to kind of keep the
hype going keep the fandom talking and
one of the big cards that they are still
holding is the identity of this
Ravenclaw companion so I think it's just
something that they decided to hold back
on and then reveal at a later date now
there was some talk for a while as to
whether or not we'll have more than four
companions so we're thinking three that
we've already seen plus one other from
Ravenclaw so that'd be one from each
house and I just keep going back and
forth on this I mean we've seen our
character in battle with someone like
fig who I don't think fig will be an
actual companion to us but I could see a
number of different characters that we
meet throughout the game kind of joining
us for a time but then again I don't
know maybe that's what they mean by
companion it's anyway maybe the
companions are not going to stick with
us throughout the whole game and go with
us on every single Mission I guess I'm
thinking too much of something like
Persona here whereas instead perhaps
they're leaning more into the side of
hey these are just characters that you
meet throughout the game and if you
choose because we know that the missions
we've seen with Sebastian and natsai are
both Optical quests which is absolutely
incredible to still think that we've
only scratched the surface of everything
in this game is just amazing now if you
guys have enjoyed a couple of my videos
make sure you hit that subscribe button
before you go I can't thank you enough
for all your support as always thank you
all so much for watching I'll talk to
you again soon